by the way before Co did you ever think
that you and I were going to go through
an epidemic or pandemic where we're
going to be told that you know we're
going to shut down everything you're
going to be working from home you better
quarantine put the mask on have gloves
on when you're going out there don't
touch this don't do that kid stay home
did you think that like did that thought
even cross your mind when 2019 was going
into 2020 and you're preparing in
December did you say honey we better be
ready for a potential pandemic to happen
we did not think about it and then all
of a sudden boom we were hit with it
right you know it's so one thing no
one's talking about that is very likely
that could happen a power outage so
imagine powered outage happens No Light
No fridge food is no longer good no
phone charger phone is done no internet
what happens to your life FYI come on
Pat that would never happen to us well
let me give you our score on how good
we're doing with power Energy System the
American Society of civil engineers
which gave the US Energy System a c
minus on great on its 2021
infrastructure report car said that the
grid investment Trends will eventually
lead to a funding gap of almost $200
billion in 2029 and also in 2021 threat
assessment from the office of the
Director of National Intelligence stated
that Russia China Iran and North Korea
have the capability to cause harm to the
energy grid What also at the same time
the Energy Secretary Jennifer granholm
confirmed that America's adversaries
possess the capability to shut down the
grit what we're going to talk about that
today so look I've been in the financial
industry since 9/11 the day before 911
and I've owned stocks bonds mutual funds
real estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Harford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold gold a precious metal
dealer you can trust they have the
finest products amazing customer service
and a buyback commitment they've earned
a five-star rating from thousands of
reviews and an A+ from the Better
Business Bureau tell them I send you and
they'll send you up to $5,000 worth of
free silver on your first order so click
on a link in the description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 okay so if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
I'm going to give you some good news and
some bad news here's some good news for
the good news is the average US
electricity consumer experienced of
interruptions annually remained
consistently at around 2 hours per year
from 2013 to 2021 we're lucky if you
look at these charts here this right
here shows us the blue is with major
events the navy blue is without major
events of course 2017 2020 2021 maybe
weather maybe additional things that
happen we experiened a little bit but
around 2 hours per year on average now
here's the bad news the bad news is much
of the US electric grid
was built in the 60s and the 7s we're
talking 70 years ago is when it was
built currently over 70% of the US
electricity grid is more than 25 years
old according to the White House so
we've updated almost everything yeah
let's upgrade this upgrade that our
electricity grid 70% of it hasn't been
updated for more than 25 years what
really maybe it's something no
president's looking at right they're
like well it's not really a threat we
shouldn't look at this here now you may
say come on Pat of course the
government's going to be paying
attention to this kind of stuff because
this is on us this is not free market we
don't do this right now somebody else
could maybe figure it out this is the
government's responsibility and us
taxpayers we'll pay our taxes yeah I
think they kind of know what they're
doing in DC Pennsylvania right I mean
they they're they're smart people we
elected them watch this on October 18th
2023 Biden Harrison Administration
announced $3.5 billion for largest ever
investment in America's electric grid
you know what the budget was the deficit
was at that time $1.7 trillion what is
$35 billion not a lot so now where is
our vulnerability like where are some
areas we should be worried about number
one extreme weather abnormal heat or
cold tornadoes hurricanes flood or
storms major power outages from weather
related events in the US increased by
67% since 2000 number two cyber security
the 2020 Homeland threat assessment from
the Department of Homeland Security
stated that China has the capability and
possible intent to compromise the energy
grid what would that look like would
China want to do that if they did
wouldn't they probably blame somebody
else like they did with covid when it
came out from Wuhan and they said no it
probably came from some kind of a you
know other place but it's not us it's
somebody else you think China would take
responsibility for it of course not they
haven't for a recent one you think
they're going to for this number three
is EMP an electromagnetic pulse also
referred to as a transient
electromagnetic disturbance Ted is a
brief burst of electromagnetic energy
the origin of EMP can be natural or
artificial and can occur as an
electromagnetic field there are two
potential sources for an EMP the
deliberate detonation of a nuclear
device in the atmosphere above the Earth
or a massive solar flare the concept
consquences of either could range from a
few days without power to lifechanging
number four is actual physical attacks
on power grid which rose by 71% last
year compared to 2021 the department of
energy strategy does not include a
complete assessment of all the cyber
security risk to the grid by the way the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
does not have a good understanding of
the scale of the potential impacts from
the impact and in the first 8 months of
2022 the US electrical grid was
physically attacked 107 times so let's
actually go through process and by the
way this is not like a horror movie
you're watching this is you're probably
listening to this saying this is very
possible and you and I just like one day
you know they say death and taxes are
the two guarantees in life this is why
you should own life insurance and this
is why you should pay your taxes because
those two things we're going to have to
do right watch this what would happen if
the power grid actually did go down
number one immediate disruption would be
a loss of electricity in affected areas
this would disrupt the normal
functioning of various aspects of our
daily life including traffic lights
public transports businesses hospitals
communication Networks works and more
number two water supply many water
supply systems rely on electric pumps
without electricity water treatment
plants may not function potentially
leading to a lack of clean water and
increased risk of waterborne diseases
number three Transportation traffic
lights would go out leading to traffic
jams and potentially accidents electric
trains and subway would halt fuel
stations might not be able to pump gas
leading to shortage of fuel for vehicles
number four communication cell towers
have backup generators but they can run
out of fuel if not replenished this this
could disrupt mobile phone service and
the internet hampering emergency
response and communication among the
public number five healthc care while
hospitals have emergency generators a
prolonged outage could endanger patients
especially those in intensive care units
or those dependent on powered medical
devices number six food supply
Refrigeration would be lost leading to
spoilage of perishable foods without a
functioning transportation system the
movement of goods would be hampered
leading to shortages in grocery stores
by the way we saw a food supply during
Co it's not like this is just 50 years
ago this just happened 2 3 years ago
economic impact prolonged outages could
lead to a significant economic Lawes as
businesses shut down and the cost of
response and Recovery amounts again this
shouldn't be intimidating this just
happened 3 years ago you know what
happened to so many restaurants in
America they had to shut down what
happened to restaurants in California
New York and Illinois they're like look
we can't make this happen what can we do
with this they went out of business next
one Safety and Security an an increase
in crime especially looting could be
observed due to reduced surveillance not
functioning alarm system and dark
streets again this civil unrest happened
during Co just a few years ago
dependency on backup power entities with
backup generators would need to rely on
them but fuel could run out if there's
no quick resolution to the crisis next
cooling and heating depending on the
season lack of electricity could result
to the inability to heat homes in Winter
or cool them in the summer posing health
risks to vulnerable populations next
environmental concerns in some cases
power outages could lead to uncontrolled
releases from industrial sites affecting
air and water quality next long-term
impact if attack damage is critical
infrastructure components it could take
weeks or even months to repair
especially if custom components are
required social implications a long-term
outage could lead to social unrest
decreased trust in government and
institutions and psychological impacts
due to the stress of prolonged
disruption by the way social
implications have we experienced this
prolonged disruption psychological
impacts to kids who were forced to stay
home imagine what happened to marriages
husband and wife like it was a very
messy situation but couple things to be
thinking of so like f so what's the
solution well we got a few things to be
thinking about there's three things that
comes to my mind number one is we have
to vote better leaders and we our job is
to bring this issue to the top of who be
elect and ask the question in interviews
if you go to a town hall ask the
question what are you going to do with
the power grid in the US we were not
prepared for Co are you if you're able
to go online and ask the question POS it
to other people ask it from your elected
officials your Congressman your Senator
your Governor your president everybody
because this should be local to your
mayor as well because a mayor is your
city what are they going to be doing
about it in your city so that's the
government level number two business the
company you're working for ask the
question are we protected what do we
have what are we looking at with our
software what what do we have to be
protected against cyber security attacks
are we protected is there dep Department
in the company that invests into that
you these are conversations that anybody
can bring up in the next leadership
meeting you could be one person that
Sparks this conversation say I watch
this video do you know what we're going
through how are we protected against
this and last but not least personal
what can you do about it for your family
is it generator is it getting the right
insurance policies to protect against
identity theft against somebody stealing
your information all of these things are
very realistic the Deep fake there's so
many different ways they're getting
people to destroy their lives but the
reality of it is those three things you
control more of it the lower you go you
control less with the government less
with the company but you definitely
control what you do with your family so
the preparation the responsibility goes
to you and I when it comes to personal
what we can do for us by the way to me
you know these types of conversations
some sometimes people watch like oh my
God babe the end of the world what am I
going to be doing no the whole idea is
to be overly prepared proper preparation
prevents poor performance we had a
conversation earlier about a script for
a movie I said we got to be hard on the
script we got to be hard on the content
we got to be the more prepared we are
Upfront for a party the more we can
enjoy the party the less prepared you
are for a party you're going to have a
miserable party cuz nothing's going
right so you can't even enjoy your own
party make sense so the more prepared we
are yeah guess what future looks bright
if you're not gu what it doesn't look
bright for those that are not prepared
so do take the time to be prepared for
you and your family if you do that you
don't have a lot to worry about having
said that if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel and I got another video I
want you to watch we did a video on food
shortages if you've never seen that
before click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye
oh